all right so let's talk about the
difference between institutional
exchanges and retail exchanges most of
you are probably familiar with retail
crypto exchanges these are places like
coinbase or gemini kraken block fi etc
these exchanges are really great to
onboard people they have super slick
interfaces you can usually trade on a
mobile app and they're a great place for
folks to get started but large
institutions come in and they trade too
much money for these retail exchanges
the fees are too high and there's some
other big technical impediments so what
ends up happening is the institutional
exchanges are where institutions go
trade obviously i'll use an extreme
example somebody like lmax digital now
lmax digital you've probably never never
heard of before the reason why you've
never heard of them before is because
they only serve institutions they're the
number one institutional exchange
and the reason why they only serve
institutions is because it's a different
type of product than that retail product
retail products super slick interface
really built for the individual user the
institutional exchanges usually have a
ton of api support and they're built
specifically to handle large trades high
frequency of volume and they have to be
super super resilient you can't go down
when there's any level of volatility and
that's where something like lmax digital
really thrives so we've got a couple of
charts that we're going to show you that
really highlight the difference between
the retail and institutional market
first here you can see that the total
monthly trading volume and bitcoin
traded has been rising rapidly if you go
all the way back to january 2020 you can
see there was five billion dollars of
monthly trading volume and then all the
way up to 74 billion dollars in may of
21. so really really incredible growth
on something like these institutional
exchanges the next chart that we have
here shows
the
uh three most important factors to
consider when selecting one of these
cryptocurrency trading venues and so you
can see reliability of technology the
number one thing there's plenty of
retail exchanges that people
continuously joke about oh it always
goes down when price moves too much
institutional exchanges can't do that
they have to stay up they also have to
have very deep liquidity if people are
going to come and trade tens of millions
hundreds of millions of dollars at a
time you have to have the liquidity on
the exchange to be able to support that
and then lastly low latency and
certainty of execution what this means
is you can't have a ton of slippage
institutions need to know that if
they're hooking into your api or they're
trying to do high frequency trading that
you're not going to have a ton of
latency and when they say buy or sell
it's actually going to get executed at
the price that they want very very
important for these institutional
exchanges the next one here is
what do you see as the most significant
infrastructure gap in today's crypto
market you can see one access to banking
the institutions are having trouble
getting banking for their digital or
crypto focused trading so that's getting
improved but definitely the number one
thing also access to credit or lack of
global regulation or some of those other
top things that this report put forward
from arcane research and lmax digital
and then next we have
a chart that shows in the next three
years which two segments of the crypto
market will account for the most volumes
traded obviously asset managers and
funds and banks no surprise here they
come into the market with much much
bigger dollars than let's say retail
clients or even corporations so more and
more this market is going to see
institutional participation everyone
from large financial
institutions all the way to the
multi-billion dollar hedge funds that
are coming in really trying to figure
out what is their strategy in this
market and then lastly you can see that
we've got this chart that shows the
average bitcoin trade size by exchange
now this is a fascinating chart again
using the extreme example of lmax
digital only institutional exchange they
don't support retail you can see that
they are head and shoulders above
bitstamp kraken bitflyer coinbase gemini
bitfinex bittrex it bit and binance us
now why are the ace so much bigger it's
because it's only institutions it's a
completely different market and so if we
go and we look at
lmax digital's actual
uh performance year to date they've had
over 350 billion dollars of total traded
volume in the first half of 2021. 350
billion dollars is a big big number and
then you can also see that they're doing
about
2.5 billion dollars of adv and they've
had a record high trading a 6.6 billion
dollars in one single day back in may
and so when you start to see these
institutions coming in it's just a
completely different beast and
understanding the differences is
important one of the key features of
these institutional exchanges that i
think people aren't aware of is not only
that deep liquidity not only that
resilience but also low latency remember
if you think of wall street now most of
the people who are sitting on that
trading floor on wall street at the new
york stock exchange it's more for
performance
art
they're not actually there trading that
much right most of the trading on wall
street is done via computers via apis et
cetera it has been digitized it is now a
battle of the quants it is now a battle
of whose computers can execute trades
faster
that is what is coming to crypto as well
you're going to see this more and more
and so these institutional exchanges
like lmax digital that's their job is to
basically focus on how do we get
reliability on our exchange how do we
consider and make sure every time that
there's high volatility we have high up
time two we have to have deep liquidity
but three we have to have that low
latency and so that's the big difference
here between uh the retail exchanges and
also these institutional exchanges last
but not least fees obviously the big
institutions they come in size they are
not going to pay the same fees that you
see retail traders trade uh paying and
so these institutional uh exchanges tend
to be lower fees as well as the higher
up dyn more resilience deeper liquidity
and also uh kind of lower latency and so
it's a pretty incredible system that
we're seeing be built right in front of
our eyes omax digital specifically uh
they're able to leverage lmac's group
which previously was in foreign
currencies and other types of assets
they're basically leveraging all of that
infrastructure and also the clients of
lmax group for lmax digital so those
guys have a great head start i've had
david mercer on the podcast before uh
incredible guy they've built a really
really cool business so i think people
just need to continue to pay attention
institutional participation is just
getting started in the market we're
going to see them come in more and more
and i think that we're going to start
hearing more stories about these
institutional exchanges that are
obviously providing a different product
to a different type of market
participant and i think that we're gonna
see tons of volume flow to the
institutional exchanges so keep your eye
out stay educated on it and uh and we'll
see how it goes what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're going to be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you ten dollars in bitcoin for free
it's that simple head on over to
sofi.com to get started today thanks so
much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more of the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]
you